يتمسك هؤلاء بموقفهم يرفضون رفع سن
التقاعد في فرنسا
ولهذا باتت الشوارع والمرافق الاقتصاديه
هدفا لتحركاتهم
الحكومه تصر انها لن تحيد عن تطبيق ما
تسميه اصلاح نظام التقاعد فما هي اسباب
الشقاق بين الفرنسيين وحكومتهم
ينص التعديل القانون على رفع سن التقاعد
من 62 الى 64 عاما تدريجيا وصولا لعام
2030 وزياده مده الاشتراكات المطلوبه في
الضمان الاجتماعي من 42 الى 43 عاما لكي
يحصل المتقاعد على معاشه كاملا اتفقت
النقابات على رفض التعديل لكن المهن
الاكثر تضررا هي تلك التي يستفيد العاملون
فيها من التقاعد المبكر مثل عمال السكك
الحديديه وسائقي القطارات حيث سيتم توحيد
التقاعد في نظام واحد قائم على النقاط
ويخشى العمال انه بموجب نظام التقاعد
الجديد سيتعين عليهم العمل لفتره اطول
وزياده الاقتطاعات من رواتبهم اما الحكومه
فترى في النظام الجديد محاوله لجعل نظام
المعاش التقاعدي قابلا للاستمرار
توفير قرابه 19 مليار دولار من ميزانيه
الدوله سنويا
وتنفق فرنسا بحسب اركان رسميه قرابه 14%
من الناتج المحلي على برنامج التقاعد
مقابل 57
في الولايات المتحده وعشره واربعه اعشار
في المئه في المانيا لكن معدلات الضرائب
في فرنسا تعتبر من الاعلى اوروبيا ولهذا
اقترحت النقابات بدائل على الحكومه تتركز
حول فرض ضرائب عادله على الاثرياء ورفع
مساهمه ارباب العمل في صناديق التقاعد وهو
ما ترفضه الحكومه فالغضب الشعبي الذي
تشهده المدن الفرنسيه ينبع من خشيه حقيقيه
لدى الفرنسيين ان يكون تعديل قانون
التقاعد خطوه اولى ستقربهم اكثر مما
يسميها ايمانويل ماكرون اصلاحات اقتصاديه
تخشى النقابات ان يدفع ثمنها اصحاب الدخل
المحدود